le le président de la commission madame
et et Monsieur le le rapporteur chers
collègues je reprendrai pour débuter mon
propos le propos de notre collègue
Philippe boncarer le retour du
Parlement nous savons depuis quelques
semaines depuis quelques mois que le
Parlement ne fonctionne pas de manière
comment dire idéal nous le voyons à
l'Assemblée nous en sommes 13e
engagement de responsabilité du
gouvernement motion de censure mais dans
ce paysage parlementaire il y a un îllo
de sérieux de
robustesse parlementaire et législative
et de travaux accomplis ce qui n'empêche
pas d'ailleurs les affrontements c'est
le
Sénat et donc cette motion de renvoi je
vais tenter de vous convaincre de la
voter parce que je pense qu'il ne faut
pas malmener notre démocratie
parlementaire et et que c'est pour cela
qu'il faut la voter et que ce serait
l'honneur du Sénat pour trois raisons la
première monsieur le ministre vous
n'êtes pas
prêt ce texte a connu un parcours pour
le moins chaotique il a été adopté il y
a un an au Conseil des ministres il est
venu une première fois devant la
commission des lois le 15 mars dernier
inscrit à l'ordre du jour puis
désinscrit
8 mois plus tard le voilà en séance
entre-temps vous avez produit un nombre
d'annonces successives non toujours
suivi des fait
d'ailleurs vous vouliez expulser tous
ceux qui manifestent une adhésion à une
idéologie djihadiste radicale un autre
jour expulser tous les fichiers s un
troisème jour augmenté à 18 mois la
rétention qui était aujourd'hui de 90
jours vous êtes aujourd'hui bien seul il
faut bien le dire même si je note qu'une
de vos collègues a estimé devoir venir
au banc du gouvernement monsieur dusopt
a disparu et euh alors qu'il est
signataire du projet de loi le garde des
sauts est momentanément empêché mais
nous aurons l'occasion de demander sa
présence puisque nous avons compris
qu'il pouvait faire plusieurs choses à
la fois et notamment siéger ici sur le
banc du gouvernement lorsque les
articles qui le concernne viendront en
séance vous avez depuis lors déposé 28
amendement sans avis du Conseil d'État
évidemment sans étude d'impact et donc
aujourd'hui à l'évidence la succession
de vos annonces montre que ce texte
n'est pas abouti ensuite je le dirai au
président buffet la commission n'est pas
prête tout d'abord la commission a
adopté un texte singulièrement modifié
composé d'un tiers de membres de cette
commission qui qui ne sont plus parmi
nous donc lorsque nos collègues Jourda
et boncère s'expriment je ne sais pas au
nom de quel collègu il s'expriment
puisqueun tiers d'entre eux n'est plus
des
nôtres
ensuite nous avons noté lors de l'examen
par cette commission c'est un fait assez
atypique me semble-t-il que sur deux
articles majeurs les articles 3 et les
articles 4 la commission n'avait pas
d'avis les rapporteurs n'étaient pas
d'accord j'indiquerai d'ailleurs au
ministre quelque chose qui m'a paru
extrêmement étrange au point qu'il a
fallu que je vérifie avec mes collègue
si je ne m'étais pas trompé dans votre
discours de présentation du texte pas un
mot sur ces articles difficiles et j'ai
trouvé très étrange que rien n'a été
dessiné de l'accord possible qui était
semble-t-il envisagé je dis cela parce
que je lis le journal et non parce que
cela se passe en commission nous avons
on vu ensuite arriver 28 amendements du
Gouvernement puis 32 amendements du
rapporteur aujourd'hui des rapporteurs
aujourd'hui même et c'est pour vous dire
que je ne suis pas la seule je pense à
trouver que la Commission n'est pas
totalement n'a pas totalement fait
aboutir ses travaux c'est que le
ministre de l'Intérieur a estimé devoir
initier une réunion délocalisée de la
Commission dans la salle à manger de
Beauvau ce qui prouve bien et ce à cette
occasion le président retaillot et moi
ce n'est pas coutumier nous étons
d'accord avec le fait que les travaux
parlementaires se tenait au Parlement et
non dans cette salle à manger même si on
m'a dit que le déjeuner était
excellent le troisème point qui fait que
cette motion de renvoi était je n'étais
pas là Monsieur le Ministre donc vous
étiez sans doute en très bonne compagnie
le troème point qui mène à ce
que cette motion de droit voie doit être
votée c'est que le Sénat n'est pas
prêt nous avons noté que le groupe LR a
déposé une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle qui de mon point de
vue fait système avec le texte dont nous
débattons aujourd'hui pour ma part
j'aurais trouvé logique que le projet de
loi d'aujourd'hui soit débattu après la
proposition de loi constitutionnelle qui
porte en grande partie sur les sujets
d'immigration et donc il me semble que
si le groupe LR qui est très important
ici voulait un travail cohérent il
demanderait l'inscription de ce projet
de loi après l'examen de la proposition
de loi
constitutionnel ensuite on note une
certaine instabilité au Sénat on a
l'habitude des choses bien faites on
arrive en séance la majorité sénatoriale
certes composée de deux groupes
essentiels je ne veuxis que ces
personnes travaille ensemble
l'opposition s'oppose manière la plus
efficace possible mais je dois dire que
le résultat de notre opposition est
souvent assez
relatif mais dans le cas présent les
articles 3 et 4 et la me font l'objet
semblet-il de grandes difficultés entre
vous au point qu'à l'heure où nous
parlons nous ne savons absolument rien
de ce que vous
entendez ce sur quoi vous entendez
délibérer au point que l'on me dit ça
restera entre nous mais oui Roger
carucci il y a débat que vous pourriez
demander la réserve des articles 3 et 4
afin de pouvoir en débattre vendredi je
trouve que c'est une excellente idée
pour nos collègues moi personnellement
j'ai prévu d'être là toute la semaine
mais je l'indique à certains réservez
votre vendredi car c'est ce jour-là que
le débat peut-être aura lieu donc nous
le voyons tout cela n'est pas très
sérieux et très instable alors en
conclusion je me suis demandé pourquoi
le gouvernement s'obstinait et pourquoi
le ministre de l'Intérieur s'obstinait à
vouloir présenter ce projet de loi est
arrivé le drame
d'aras et à partir du drame d'aras nous
avons entendu le ministre de l'Intérieur
s'appuyer sur ce fait terrible pour
expliquer que ce projet de loi était
indispensable et de manière un petit peu
excessive estimer que si ce projet de
loi avait été en vigueur le drame d'
race aurait pu peut-être être
évité je regrette ces propos
pourquoi je pense que d'une part le
ministre aurait dû noter et soutenir ses
services car dans le drame d'arace les
services de police ont fonctionné il se
trouve
que il se trouve que la sécurité totale
n'existe pas et que lorsque vous
indiquez que si ce projet de loi avait
été voté aras ne se serait pas produit
ce n'est pas exact et donc vous utilisez
et instrumentalisez quasiment cette ce
terrible ce terrible
meurtre pour expliquer qu'il faut voter
ce projet comme une sorte
d'assurance que vous voulez construire
pour éviter d'être mise en cause
ultérieurement peut-être lorsque un
drame analogue pourrait se reproduire
donc au bénéfice de l'ensemble de ces
constats
d'impréparation de manquement et de
difficultés à déterminer une position
stable sur un sujet sérieux nous
souhaitons que la Commission puisse
retravailler afin que dans les jours qui
viennent nous puissions proposer un
texte qui soit à la hauteur de ses
ambitions